tu veux lui dire quelque chose pourquoi
vous croyez comme ça il est brûlé il est
passé
il y a juste du mal à s'exprimer
[Musique]
vous êtes cinéphile
c'est vrai que j'aime bien me faire une
petite toile de temps en temps je suis
fan de tout ce qui est film catastrophe
volcano twister le pic de Dante
[Musique]
là justement Michel on y va
des gonzesses qui nous apprennent à
conduire c'est la meilleure ça
[Musique]
bonjour à tous Pauline Cloarec
formatrice psychologue alors d'après
vous l'utilité du port de la ceinture je
vous l'ai déjà dit je la mets pas je la
mets pas je ne supporte pas
vous avez toujours été formatrice à la
base je suis psychologue les gonzesses
qui nous apprennent à conduire c'est la
meilleure ça m'a donné envie de
m'investir dans la sécurité routière
essayer d'éduquer les automobilistes
mais bon c'est pas tous les jours facile
non
identifié retrouvé dans le coffre d'une
Passat 1000
alors vous votre truc du chauffard
bah oui je fais de la prévention
routière
notre croquettes prend une tournure là
j'avais bien quand vous êtes émoustillé
comme ça là on avance allez allez
[Musique]